53 and i'll get to that in more detail
in just a moment getting back to the
subject of democracy sent that that's
something that bush and everyone is
talking about right now uh i remind you
of chile in 1973 the cia organized the
overthrow
of salvador allende the democratically
elected president of chile and he was
killed in the process and we killed
general schneider who was the pro-us
defender of the constitution there in
order to put the ci's representative
pinochet in power and henry kissinger's
when he was grilled by the congress over
this program his rationale was yes the
issues are much too important for the
chilean voters to be left to decide for
themselves
now there was a long ci destabilization
and propaganda campaign against china
we were parachuting teams from kemoi
matsu
tibet burma thailand to destabilize
china with the propaganda campaign the
propaganda aimed at the united states as
well as
china and other parts of the world until
eventually we talked ourselves into the
korean war
in which a million people where we
fought china in korea and a million
people were killed there was a long ci
destabilization and propaganda campaign
against vietnam until we talked
ourselves into going into vietnam to
fight and two million people were killed
again read for yourselves read bill
blum's book the cia of forgotten history
read portrait of a cold warrior by
joseph burkholder smith who was a ci
case officer in southeast asia
reed fire in the lake by francis
fitzgerald the daughter of desmond
fitzgerald the famous ci chief of
operations of southeast asia
read deadly deceits by ralph mcgee
another case officer who served in
southeast asia read decent interval
by frank snap who covered the period of
time in vietnam 73 75 he and i were
colleagues there at that time or if you
will read my own book in search of
enemies by norton which remains the only
insider's detailed account of the of the
inner functionings of a covert action or
read washington's war on nicaragua by
holly sklar not written by an insider
but a remarkable detail on the
nicaraguan operation great detail of how
that operation has been run
trying to come to grips with these ci
activities in these broad numbers trying
to figure out how many people have been
killed you can count it up different
ways you can never be sure how many
people are killed in the jungles of of
laos or the hills of nicaragua but
adding them up as best we can we come up
with a figure of six million people
killed minimum figure it has to be more
than that a million in the korean war
two million in the vietnam war eight
hundred thousand in indonesia a couple
of million in cambodia 20 000 in angola
the operation i was part of 22 000 in
nicaragua
again the figure the new york times
sites you're dealing with large numbers
of people who died who would not have
died if our tax dollars had not been
spent by the cia to exacerbate
situations and destabilize and set
people to fight